jason momoa and lisa bonet have called
it quits after being together for 16
years the aquaman star took to instagram
to announce the news of their separation
on wednesday writing quote we have all
felt the squeeze and changes of these
transformational times a revolution is
unfolding and our family is of no
exception
filling and growing from the seismic
shifts occurring and so we share our
family news that we are parting ways in
marriage
he goes on to say quote we share this
not because we think it's newsworthy but
so that as we go about our lives we may
do so with dignity and honesty the love
between us carries on evolving in ways
it wishes to be known and lived we free
each other to be who we are learning to
become
jason added that quote our devotion
unwavering to the sacred life in our
children teaching our children what's
possible living the prayer may love
prevail
j l
it's beautiful to go through so many
different
challenges in our lives and have a
partner that loves you through all of it
so the two actors have been together
since 2005 but the pair officially tied
the knot in october of 2017.
they share two children together
daughter lola who's 14 and son nicola
wolfe who's 13.
jason is also the stepfather to actress
zoe kravitz lisa bonet's daughter with
ex-husband lenny kravitz
when it comes to being a father in
august during the promotion of his film
sweet girl jason opened up to e.t about
his desire to protect his daughter lola
and son nicola wolfe from the spotlight
speaking of you and your lovely wife
some incredible acting jeans could you
put them in one of your movies one day
would you say man one of them wants to
do it i'm not a fan and i don't want
them them too but uh
i don't know i'll try as my i'll try my
damn just to keep them out of it
really but you don't you love it
i love storytelling i love back to
filmmaking so i mean i like you know
directing and filmmaking but
um i just
i want them to you know go for other
things you know i want them to really to
go for other things and if they want to
maybe
but i don't want them to get into acting
it's very hard
very hard it's very hard on people and
uh
you know i don't want them to have that
kind of pressure i'm tough enough to
handle it but i wouldn't want to put
someone i loved
[Music]